[Music]
got that contract means you're gonna
start grabbing up it worked James that's
great probably gonna have a lot of late
nights ago I'm gonna ask Owen to help
out around the house our old neighbor
O'Leary
he meets the money and honestly I need
the help phone thank you no problem
I'll go start on cleaning the house way
I can't believe you fixed it I have been
on James for a week to fix this thing
you name it there's a good chance I'm
dying
have I told you how amazing you are I
never get tired of hearing it
[Applause]
and in 201 looks like he's got the door
fixed check it out yeah that was nice of
him I was gonna fix it but now you don't
have to you help me pick out a nanny-cam
today to set it up and everything you
can install it on your laptop if you
want to keep an eye on Riley what do you
think should we keep an eye I think we
should you're beautiful James can't see
owe me more he's a stupid music keep it
down please with a baby inside shiny
slippery
get out guy stands out for you this is
how he gets treated I know you didn't
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you